remember bado yesterday he said that
earth only has ten years left if no
action is taken on climate change I want
to make sure that those who work in the
oil and gas industry those who work in
the fossil fuel industry are brought
along as partners to make sure that we
make this transition in the ten years
that we have left to us as the science
and scientists tell us so now it's ten
years to save humanity he proposes
spending five trillion over three
decades I don't get it but anyway this
begs the question why I'm thinking he
saw aoc claim we only had 12 years left
and he thought oh yeah I can do it in
ten it's like a hysterical version of
name that tune - the tunes just the
loons
so why the return to global scare
tactics I blame Trump America's
economy's booming unemployment for
everyone is at a historic low
manufacturing jobs returned by the
hundreds of thousands there are people
working now who never worked a day in
their lives look at Jessie Trump no
longer works we're now back to Chicken
Little Theater of course this won't stop
bado
from using jets trains or automobiles
rationing is for the little people but
not for him poor pay oh just a month ago
he was the media's BFF a walking
sandwich board of earnest platitudes
propped up by family wealth that masks
decades of failure to Vanity Fair he was
King to the rest of us he reminded us of
that dorm roommate haya nodos who
lectures everyone about stuff he knows
nothing about a motivational speaker in
search of an audience but the act is
running dry mayor Pete is smarter plus
he can speak without inflicting
collateral damage on bystanders I'm done
Dagan what do you make of his plan five
trillion it well the whole thing doesn't
work right okay just tell the American
people that they're gonna have to pay
five six seven dollars for gasoline that
oh by the way we've reduced power plant
emissions in this country by 30 percent
since 2005 because of private industry
because we are discovering more and more
natural
prices are collapsing this energy
industries created millions of jobs but
I'm gonna wipe all of that away just for
a campaign slogan good luck on that but
this is just a sign of desperation the
world's worst Cologne so Eric's Wawa
will clearly corner the corner the himbo
vote that's gone mayor Pete and his
husband and his two dogs very authentic
very charming the family and then he
doesn't look enough like a Kennedy to
get that voting bloc to care done yeah
he's half a Kennedy Jesse I think Peter
was just basically like hooked his wagon
to aoc him today that I would not leave
my wagon to a si what do you say I know
she said that his plan was not bold
enough oh oh there you go that's what I
would say Greg and I'm still smarting
from the itself from the commentary all
right we'll talk about that in the
commercial it's worth repeating if
someone calls you on the phone and says
you're gonna die in ten years unless you
give me all of your money right that's a
scam and he's a scam artist and
everybody knows that but before I rake
them over the coals I just want to go
over some facts here I brought charts
Dana like charts and diggin actually
appropriated my chart so I'm gonna give
us a lawn you're right
look at this America reducing all these
co2 emissions look at China and the EU
in India they're admitting like crazy
green new deal in order to get that done
you have to set aside the landmass of a
California just to house all of the
windmills and the solar panel rights
okay probably get out of the last ice
age anyway if there was no fossil fuels
I wonder how the earth heated up then we
can't even predict the weather next
weekend how are we going to predict what
it's going to be like in 10 years but
let's just think about how cocky beta
O'Rourke is all right first wait you're
calling somebody cocky to do that so you
have a 21 trillion dollar US economy the
fossil fuel industry runs this economy
it's created all of this wealth
revolutionised transportation
communications industry lifted people
out of poverty bado
who's done nothing except lose to Ted
Cruz comes up and says I'm gonna take
five trillion dollars and I'm
reverse everything in 10 years and
change it all he's no Einstein he's no
Carnegie where does he get off thinking
he's gonna stop human progress
pump the brakes because the real reason
he's doing this he feels guilty of the
success the American economy is sad
because he and other liberals have not
had enough input in it one how is he
gonna go on another like a
soul-searching tour without fossil fuels
I think the news here is to get 80 plus
percent of Democrats saying this is
their number-one issue I think that's
you know just looking because you have I
mean in some places you say it was
health care or education but now today
eighty-one percent saying that this is
the number one issue so you know I argue
with Jesse with day even with these guys
about climate change and it never
changes anything except against me
heated so I will say this let's not
argue about it but we can't argue about
the fact that Democrats think this is
very important it's not just beta when
it's not just AOC you have a clear
majority a super majority Democrats who
say this is our number one issue and you
have politicians in a representative
government saying we are going to speak
to your issue voters we're gonna try to
do something about it
Republicans aren't speaking to climate
change which is what opens the door for
these kind of proposals I think Dana
that one is right in the sense that
there that we could as a Republican say
we because I'm not a Democrat speak
about climate change by talking about
the nuclear power the fact that solar
and wind are so diluted but you need
it's environmentally environmentally
terrible for the planet can't store it
you can't store it to mean they're
working on it'll never happen but but
the other thing is so in a in the
previous polls where people have been
asked do you like the idea of Medicare
for all people was like yeah like that
do you like Medicare for all if that
means that it's going to cost excellent
oh no I don't like that yeah so in this
poll I would have liked for the
Democrats to be asked okay so if climate
change is your number one issue if I
asked you we're going to solve that by
you
nuclear power do you support that mm-hmm
and what it would the number be yeah
probably because of misinformation and
yeah uneducated people about nuclear
power it would probably be down around
forty percent when that is actually the
only true way that you get all of those
other countries to yeah reduce their
emission I mean nuclear power has come a
long way it there's a there's a fewer
belt obviously fewer meltdowns gen4 and
nuclear reactors hopefully are better
and they feed off their own waste so
that's good and I would add that
Republicans in order to get in on that
opening they should go for conservation
you know it's heady Roosevelt situation
a lot of the western governors are
Republican they're conservationists they
love fishing they love hunting Don
Junior's a big outdoorsman he could sell
that in a heartbeat
I'm waiting I would every much more
appealing I knows he stopped a lot of I
want every liberal to be a vegan boom
there you go